sort of the essence of my like i'm sorry  we will get to the acid story no that's  fine no no it's okay  we're close we're close we're close to  the acid story okay so um have you heard  of the marketplace of ideas tim are we  in that marketplace right now are we  selling  we will walk right into the cathedral  that's a good question hey you know uh  um uh let's get some hits on this  spotify the cathedral that's an  interesting question that is an  interesting thing okay let's let's let's  let's table that one down the road i  don't want to get that deep okay okay i  want to keep this shallow you know for  your i want to it bottom out at like 95  iq okay like matt damon like janitors at  harvard  right you know  [Applause]